uh if congress passed a statute
to ask a foreign government to
investigate a political opponent it is
not currently a crime and that's why you
have to use vague terms like abuse of
power
well we'll go to truth or consequences
in new mexico democratic caller go ahead
hello good morning
allie and i feel sorry for you because
it's obvious to me that you're the
victim here
it was don't
don't feel sorry for me
epstein obviously used you and the dear
prince
um i think that you're being used again
you're obviously not able to be a very
good judge or character
but my problem and my question is
is when trump is proven to be as bad for
this country as epstein was for little
girls then will you admit that you were
wrong
and will you fade away or will you just
be deceived again thank you i don't
think i was deceived i represent people
who were accused of serious crimes i
represented o.j simpson i represented
klaus von bulow i've represented many
many people who you don't like and some
who i don't like that's my job i
represented epstein i was his lawyer he
paid me for every
minute that i spent with him
we worked out a deal with the government
that represented the comparative
strength of
our side and their side i will continue
to defend the people and the
constitution
epstein didn't use me i never met
any of the young women i didn't even
know there were young women involved
when i met him i was introduced to him
by the lady rothschild the wife of lord
rothschild i was told he was very close
friend of the president of harvard the
provost of harvard nobel prize winners
my association with him was largely
academic and then it became professional
when i represented him that's what
criminal lawyers do and to taint
criminal lawyers with the sins or crimes
of their clients is pure mccarthyism
so yes i will continue to defend the
constitution i will continue to defend
the sixth amendment i will continue to
defend people accused of crime and i'll
do it proudly because i think i'm
serving the interests of the rule of law
in the constitution bill in dallas texas
republican
yeah good morning and thanks so much for
taking the call i just would like to
know if alan could reflect on
the
relationship between the powers the the
the powers of government being judicial
executive and uh congressional
how it fits into the statement i heard
one of the committee meeting meeting
members state that
they that the congress had the sole
power to impeachment i understood that
to mean they had the sole power to
bring the charge of impeachment but then
what would be the next step and i
apologize for my ignorance thank you no
no it's an excellent excellent question
the framers use the term soul power yeah
but that doesn't mean it's not subject
to judicial review
every act of congress according to
federalist paper
78 written by hamilton is subject to
judicial review that became american law
under marbury versus madison which
implemented federalist paper 78 and so
every act of congress hamilton said that
violates the constitution is void that's
his word void
whether congress would have the power
to impeach a president on the basis of
non-constitutional criteria and whether
or not the courts could intervene in
that is a question that we just don't
know the answer to it's never been
tested may never be tested
our constitution isn't perfect
remember we needed the 25th amendment
the impeachment power didn't cover for
example
incapacity a president who didn't do
anything bad he just had a stroke and
was not capable of governing the way
woodrow wilson was not capable of
governing the last couple of years of
his presidency and so we had to amend
the constitution if we think that abuse
of power should be a criteria for
impeachment we have an obligation to
amend the constitution i doubt you'd get
a lot of votes for that because members
of congress of both parties would say oh
my god that gives far too much power to
congress abuse of power no we're not
going to vote for that just as the
framers didn't vote for mal
administration but congress can't just
add that to the constitution without
amending the constitution something i
doubt it would do if they were asked to
include abuse of power as part of the
criteria for impeachment we've
approached the top of the hour alan
dershowitz thank you for the
conversation this morning thank you
that does it for today's washington
journal we'll be back here tomorrow
morning 7 a.m eastern time enjoy the
rest of your day
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr